the year 1986 the problem toxins in
California the solution Proposition 65
making it illegal for businesses to
expose individuals to chemicals known to
cause cancer or reproductive toxicity
without first giving clear and
reasonable warning sounds like a great
idea with the best of intentions what
could possibly go wrong with the warning
requirements were established in 1988
235 chemicals made the cut today there
are over 900 compounds on The
Proposition 65 list including alcoholic
drinks salted fish Chinese style and
wood dust business owners came to the
rational conclusion that the cost of a
label was less than the cost of
litigation the result warning labels
everywhere in bars restaurants hotels
Spas ski resorts schools and Disneyland
on golf clubs lamps toasters kids toys
sunglasses potato chips pancakes pumpkin
puree and even trees